Ahoy-Hoy!
my doormat's done
but first we recap cause a few days ago
I realised that my front door was kinda ugly
and my house was covered in spiders
which was definitely just one spider
working overtime right?
right!?
anyway we're gonna skip over the part where I killed a plant
sacrifice to the gods I suppose
once I got up to this point it was time to paint my doormat
I had a few questions about it so I'm gonna tell you loosely what I did
I got a plain doormat from Mitre 10
and I bought some acrylic paints from Bunnings
PS: those two must never know that the other one exists
and I free handed a font to the best of my abilities
which admittedly is not great
but that's only cause I couldn't make a stencil
cause my printer will only print if I
pay subscription each month
which I flat out refuse to do
anyway I rubbed some knobs until they shined
highly recommend
then I sanded the door frame and I sanded the door
and then I painted the door frame and I painted the door
so painting the door was a surprise to me as well
but when you look at something really close
then you can see the imperfections and once you see them
you can't unsee them
and when you can't unsee them
they will keep you awake at night
and I had this leftover Dulux
enamel paint from our lounge renovation
called Lake Brunner
and I always thought that my front door was blue
which I liked but looking at it now I think
it's more of a dusty grey
I cut everything in and then when it was dry
went over it all with a mini roller because we
can't have any brush strokes
but we can't stop there cause you know
that one spider I told you about
turns out it's not just one and I have a problem
actually I have many problems
but today we're gonna deal with the spider specific one
and the most commonly recommended product
in my comment section was called
Miss Muffets Revenge
and I bought it solely because I like the name
and now that the paint on the doormat is dry
I'm gonna seal it because I don't know
it feels like the right thing to do
Anyway, massive side note but Alexander Graham Bell
invented the telephone right
and he wanted everyone to answer it by saying Ahoy-Hoy
but his rival Thomas Edison wanted everyone to say hello
but now only Mister Burns says
Ahoy-Hoy, and I kinda wish we all said it
anyway that was the before during and after and
I know now I need to pave it
but first I gotta get back to what I supposed to be doing